トーキョ　ﾋﾟー
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
もう今三月の後半になりました！!(^^)!
えー
皆さん、新生活始まってると思います
多分引っ越しする人もいるし、
学校卒業してほかの学校行ったり、
お仕事始めたりする人もいたりすると思うんですけども、
え～
私のこの、
はじめアミューズメントパークにも、
新しい人が、
やって来ました!!('Д')
そしてなんと…
期間は違うんですけども、
二人、
しばらく僕の家に、
一緒に住むことになります!!
じゃ1人目は
こちらの方です!!( ｀ー´)ノ
[拍手]パチパチパチパチ88888888888888888
たなっち）あ、どうもこんにちは
たなっち）たなっちです。
ということで、たなっちはもうだって
はじめ）春から静岡に住むでしょ
たなっち）住みます
たなっち）言ったら、新チャンネルがバレますよ
はじめ）大丈夫、バレねーって
はじめ）バレてねーよ
はじめ）大丈夫
はじめ）で、静岡に住むんだよね
たなっち）住みます
はじめ）そう、たなっちは春から、なんか知らないけど静岡に住むらしいです。
はじめ）で、家がもう決まってるんだよね。
はじめ）決まってるけど、入るまでにまだちょっと日があるんで、
はじめ）その間、この家に住んでいくというわけなんです
はじめ）しばらく、ちょっと動画で手伝ってもらったり、色々出ることもあるかと思います。
はじめ）よろしくお願いします。
たなっち）よろしくお願いします
たなっち）あともう一人の住人の方
はじめ）そう、実はですね。もう一人
はじめ）しばらく家に住むことになっておりますが、
はじめ）なんとですね！
はじめ）女性です！
はじめ）女性なんです。
はじめ）ちょっと女性が来るということで、すごい僕も緊張しているんですけれども
はじめ）お呼びいたしましょう。この方です。
どうぞ！
まさき）どーもー
[拍手]
まさき）誰が女性だよ、おかしいでしょ。出づらいわほんと
はじめ）で、まさきんぐはどうして静岡に？
はじめ）Youは何しに静岡に？
まさき）もう数日後に
まさき）大学院の修了式っていう、卒業式があって
まさき）それまで、もう静岡の家をひきはらってしまっているので
まさき）ここで居候を
はじめ）なるほど、なるほど。でも、もうそんないないから、
はじめ）まさきはもう、本当に最後かもしれないね。動画撮るの
まさき）そうそう、たぶん
はじめ）ちょっとうるっと来ちゃった
はじめ）まさきはもう本当に、静岡に来る最後の機会かもしれない
はじめ）この数日間、何か動画を一緒に撮れればいいなと思っているところでございます。
はじめ）まさきはもう、数日で帰ってしまって
はじめ）たなっちはもう、半永久的に静岡？
たなっち）そうですね、本当に大丈夫ですか？
はじめ）え？
たなっち）バレますよ、新チャンネルのこと
はじめ）大丈夫だよ
たなっち）バレないか
はじめ）大丈夫
はじめ）気付いてへん
たなっち）気付いてへんか
はじめ）で、静岡
たなっち）静岡です
はじめ）おう
はじめ）なんか、仕事で静岡に来るみたいなんで
はじめ）しばらくは一緒にお手伝いとかで、（動画に）出てたりすると思います。
はじめ）この動画何だろう。
はじめ）はい、というわけで、二人がしばらく家にいるんで
はじめ）何卒よろしくお願いします